(Steve Cumberton): Good morning
Hi
[clap]
Welcome all of us in our conversation today
About the new Android Developer Tools
It is amazing to see so many developers here
From around the world and in a concert theater
I want you guys to know that this is great for us
I (Steve Cumberton) I'm here today
With amazing Tor Torby and amazing beauty of Eason
We will give you a tour behind the scenes
For Android Studio
And to those who are primarily familiar with you
You noticed that Zaf is not on stage this year
I only answer him
It is on the beach in Hawaii
So hello (Zaf)
When we first started working on Android Studio
We wanted a specialized IDE
Modified specifically for our languages
That's why we chose IntelliJ, the original Android product
Now Android Studio has created tremendous momentum
In a short period
Among the things we announced yesterday
Is that now 92% of the top 125 applications and games
You are using Android Studio
Since we announced it here at the Google Developers Conference of three years
You may remember that Tor was the show
We launched it 131 times along with preview and beta versions
And stable issuances
What this reflects is indeed a large part
From our drive to success
We have a community of astoundingly committed developers
Try all our previous versions
They provide us with wonderful comments
This is what makes the team focus
It helps us to work very quickly
We've been thinking a lot over the past year about what we can do next
In order to accelerate productivity
Improve your life
If of those in the audience
Who does not know Android Studio well
I will take you on a stormy tour of 2016
And what we have achieved so far
In about 60 seconds
So I will put everyone on the same page
So we keep talking about version 2.2 and the way ahead
If this year we launched version 2.0
Which focused on speed with instant playback rendering
And simulators
We also launched the user interface for the new simulation and corrective graphics processing unit
Creating sub search links, checking and much more
And then for a short time version 2.1 that we created in collaboration with Android N
Which gives you support for all Android N features and APIs
It gives you simulators
For you to check out Android N and Jack Translator
To be able to experience Java 8 support
Specifically in version 2.1 we speed up immediate operation
We did this by changing the December step
To coincide with this process, it gave us amazing developments in speed
If all this leads us to version 2.2
Which focuses on speed and self-monitoring technology system, analysis, media and Android system support
One of the great things for us at the A / O conference
Is that the public of developers, if we do
Is a 25-minute signature of our conversation today
To give you a direct view of each feature of the experimental version 2.2
Which you can use as well
[Cheers and applause]
For reminder only, this is a trial version
So expect the quality of the trial version
So we do the natural thing that we always do
Over the coming weeks
We will stabilize it as we do
While we pass the beta system and stability
After that, we will restore him and (Jamal)
We will inform you of the design
Development, structure and testing to give you a consistent summary
With screen shots as we will take you behind the scenes
To talk more about how the features work and why
So, in order to take you on a tour of version 2.2
Please welcome (Tor Nurbi)
thank you
[clap]
Tour Norby: Well
Can you see the screen?
Display
Okay
Can we get the projector?
Thanks
Okay
If I start something
Very small and simple, but I think you will like it
If we launch a lot of components of the software development toolkit yesterday
And install Android Studio 2.2
And go to install them, they noticed how we became
Button for background now
[clap]
So you can mark up
During your installation of the latest products
If we spent the past year
We focus on making versions faster
We know that this is a great concern for you
So I want to show you where we've come in now
If this is an I / O conference application running to the right of the screen
I can go ahead and put some code here and run it
And when I make this change
You can see that in a second
This change reflects the device
It takes about 15 seconds without instant playback
I can also make some non-matching changes
For example, by extracting this in the medium
This change takes a second or two to run
After the show, Steve will talk more
About what we will do in Instant Play in version 2.2 and 2.3
So one of the things we should have done
Is to determine what happens inside the APK files
To do this, we created a new feature, the APK Analyzer
I can open any APK or in my project
Now I can dive into what happens in the file
For example, I can see what is inside the asset file
Or resource file, or in this case
Instant playback
Repack the app
So let me withdraw a real production application
Chrome APK
The purpose of this tool there are two objectives
The first is to be able to see the download size
In some markets, it is important
The loading size is small and the installation size is small
If this allows you to actually see what's inside your app
And focus on what you can get rid of
If I dive into the file I look at the files
I can see example file designs
It removes the binary XML translation and returns it to the source
Although we need to do better in resource references
We will soon assign them to resource names
You can also see the value table
Which was previously obscure
Now we have a viewer, so you can go in and see what's inside
last but not least--
[clap]
Yup
Last but not least, this lets you look at .dex files
You are probably aware of the 64k limit on the medium
Is not actually an end to the means
The limit is on the medium added to the reference
If you can now enter it and see
What you announce
And what thing you assign
In order to get to that limit or multidex occupancy
[clap]
If you ever see a data file in the construction output
You may have noticed that there are a lot of things in the data file that you did not type
Right? where are you from?
Well, we have a new editor in version 2.2 which is a data editor
If this is an XML tab, you can see it below
There is now a tab for the merged data
When you press it, you can see that we are now
We give you the complete, combined, and updated data directly whenever you edit
There is a guide on the right that tells you
Where things come from
If for example, I can see that the Internet permit
[clap]
Coming from PlayService
If I can also enter here and go to the line
Which is the source of integration
Hopefully this helps simplify
What happens in the process of integration of Gradle data
On the mention of Gradle, do not want you to learn
How to edit build files in order to adjust your project settings
We central rewrite the entire structure of the project
I say middle, because it is all we have achieved so far
Dependencies are, though perhaps the hardest part
The best section I have in developing the software package is the message board
What they refer to are the suggestions made by the interpreter
You see here that my project
Uses jCenter for dependencies
He tells me that there is
A new version of these dependencies
All I have to do is click on the update link
Now I'm using the newer version
I can also press "Update All" to select all the suggestions
Note that they do not just look
To local warehouses, which was Lint
But it also looks for remote warehouses
If you go to view Dependencies
I can go to Dependencies, either through the software module
Or considering the total dependencies of all the software units
In the project
I can go for example
Dependent dependencies to see
How do I reach some dependencies in my project
I can also add dependencies
If we have a beautiful user interface now where I can search
I repeat, as in the update suggestions
This displays remote repositories
It also displays local warehouses
Looks at all existing versions
It also helps me adjust the range
In the Dependencies list
You can run this day in the experimental settings
If you want to play it
We will try to end it
In future releases
[clap]
Let's talk about C ++
Last year, we show you that we have fantastic support
In editing
This is a Sea-lion ++ function from Jetbrains
Which we have integrated
But you need to use the experimental Gradle extension
The good news for version 2.2 is that we are now
We added support for exterior building systems
You can use the CMake to build the innards
You just have to make it with a stable attachment
You can now build C ++
For C ++, we will have a processor in the next two versions
You can add C ++ support
To your project
When you do, you have a project model
This model is exactly similar
If you have a major activity that holds the authentic library
Then you have a typical authentic library series titled "Hello World"
Let's connect these
I will initially set a breakpoint here in C ++
The main activity only displays the initial shape
Which includes a string in the middle
Let me return and change that string to show the value
From C ++
If we write text view = fine view by ID
Then we will explain the explanatory instructions ID
We go to convert it and then write set text on it
With the C ++ Connector
Let's put a stop here too
I will launch the debugger
This works by Gradle which is in turn operated by CMake
He builds everything and sets it up
In one second, this application should work on the emulator
This is
We click on the breakpoint and we convert it into the Java code
You can clearly walk around
In the case of data I mean the status of the activity
If you have completed the debugger now
Now you see that we are in C ++
[clap]
I can walk around
This is a hybrid debugger and a CMake support group
And the last thing I will show you in the area of ​​the building system
Is in the command line
Let's say you've received a project from your coworker
Or maybe you've explored Git and not one of them
Version Tools or a compiled software development toolkit
Of your project
Then you build and then click on a message like this
You do not have Construction Tools 2201 What are you doing now?
The software package management tool opens up and installs, does not it?
Well, in version 2.2 Alpha 1, we now have an experimental signal
You can select it
When I run the version, if I have
Approved this license, Gradle will
Download it for me immediately, as you can see here
[clap]
This makes tuning settings
Continuous integration servers are much easier
Okay
Let's move from the command line to visual editing
Let's look at the new design editor
In fact, I should not call it design editor because it is
It does more than just designs
First, open the options menu file
This is a list of options
I can now drag and drop the layout options menus
We can also open preference files
I can pull preference files and leave them here
Obviously, this is a Component Monitor
But of course the designs are the bulk of them
You see that we have a new observer factors
On the right, this shows you
Important properties for the worker you have selected
In this case it is text view
For example, for text view,
We show you the text format
Note that there is a gray text here in the Factors Monitor
Although I did not specify the text format
We show you how it will be
Form it directly
I can see that the font type would be 14sp for example
If you moved to something else
It will calculate what it should be
We only have a subset of the properties here
For easy searching
But if you want anything else, the whole set of characteristics
One click away here
If on the design surface, we have the status of the chart
If the position of the chart shows the shape
It is like a ray showing what the application does
I can put the position of the chart and design status
side by side
We have something you asked for
Is the scrolling option and I can scroll the design interface
directly
[Cheers and applause]
The position of the chart is particularly useful
For the new design of the
Take a look at the styling
First, close the automatic connection mode
To withdraw some factors
I will put the text view here
We edit the text, display another text and field for the password
Probably
Then add some buttons on the bottom right of the screen
You now notice that I am a little neglected
Because I can press and select
I can click on the right
I say that I want to describe these things on the left
I want to row all these things on the left
Maybe I want to pop them vertically
If I have my design here to see what will happen
If you go to the horizontal position
This is not good right?
I have some buttons off the screen
Let's try to fix it
We have this small bulb here
Indicative limitations
Notice what happens when you press it
I now have these limitations, where I tried
Guess what we mean here
And when I try to resize now
You can see that the buttons move correctly
[clap]
Normally, you are in automatic dialing mode
So if you want to pull a button here
You can see that just to pull it,
He alone adds these restrictions for me
If I did not like it,
I can cancel the restrictions by simply clicking on them
I can also withdraw the new restrictions
We offer you kind of premiere display
What they will do when they agree
Constraints can also be strong
While I pull it, you can see
They are locked alone to a quarter or to a specified percentage
One yesterday asked if he was also working through XML editing
If you prefer
And postponed, already works
You can see here, we are in XML
I can continue to manipulate restrictions here
You can see that XML editing works well
If this is strong--
[clap]
thank you
If this is a very strong solution to the constraints
Allows you to adjust your design gradients
This is very good for performance
We've added a feature to take this off
If we open another design, this design
Move to the status of the chart to see what is happening here
If this design actually longer
A set of intertwined longitudinal designs
If I go now I will say about this longitudinal design
To my design, it shows you
Adjust the entire design
As you can see, theoretically it seems the same
Except that we have limitations
On the left, you can see a single longitudinal list
[clap]
Okay
Let's take a look at the editing
In the editing section, we added two features
First, there is Firebase integration
If you are trying to accomplish a task with Firebase
For example, you want to add crash reporting
Just open the plugin window
And choose the task you want
For example, reporting faults, you enter
You see that you can get this step through a set of tutorials
Located next to the source editor
If you see an example
You want to execute these lines
Drag them to the source code to work on this edit, for example
If you're trying to figure out how to use the API
Let's say you heard that you should use the Job Scheduler application
Then, you should use the Job Scheduler
You can click on the right
And you can tell my grandfather a typical code for this
[clap]
As you can see, basically go to the server
Find suggested models that you can walk around
You can click on the right and say Open this in a browser
Let me know more about him
Version 2.2 based on IntelliJ 16.1
So we have a number of new features for this as well
The other thing that we have is support for editing
Two-way series
If this is something our global audience has demanded
From us for some time
Here we have Arabic text
· View that source editor now
Pleased to handle the matter correctly
I know this was a black point, if we finally analyzed it
Thanks IntelliJ
IntelliJ 16 also comes with a range of surveys
New in editing
Moreover, we added it
A set of new Android surveys
Let's look at them
First, I hope everyone
Know that it is bad practice
Solve the problem of transferring data from activities by making
Your field is fixed
This is unacceptable
Now Lint will warn you
Not because this is a leak, but
Because it makes instant playback work well when you do so
It is not easy this situation as well
If you make other fields here, for example
Fixed, app data 1 is not a problem, but after app data 2
This seems to have an Instant State
It is a context, but there is a constant reference to it,
This is not good
[clap]
Let's take a look at the new support comments now
We launched the support library yesterday
There are some good features in it
First, you can finally say that this is the way
With it within a working chain
These are excluded from the string
You can isolate it from any string
For a period of time, we had an API check
Lint was therefore viewed and compared to the API platform
Basic Software Development Kit
We have a quick solution where we say, well,
Enter this test for me
But what you can do now is say
I'm expecting my way to ask for this API
If you transfer responsibility
Connect them from your API
You can get the API check for your libraries to the customer
If you can see these other connections
They contact your API but the API check is applied
I will then give you the resources of dimensions
Dimensions Comments
This allows you to say that this correct number represents a dimension
There are many modules that you can apply
Bixal seems to be very important
Most APIs in the Software Development Kit work in Pixel
So we have a new comment to determine the bixalat
If you type @ px when I do this
You can see misuse warnings
Where the supplier recognizes dimensions and should be dimensioned
I hope this is useful
And the last comment I want to highlight
Keep is suspended
If you can write Keep @ on your devices and categories
And postponed
[clap]
As of the Gradle 2.2 extension, we automatically do
If you use ProGuard or
The new Incremental Shrinker ensures that these devices will not be released at launch
If you like the explanatory support comments
Our advantage I think it
It will make it more useful to you
It is the new induction engine
If IntelliJ has a specific time, the Analysis option
To infer the invalidity
We now have a new feature, it's under the alarm now
But you can try it if you want to infer support comments
So when I run this on the current file
Performs a whole set of analyzes
In order to identify a lot of new comments build
On use in your project
If you return to my file here
All the div tags you see here are for new comments
Which I drew
For example, access is required
We hope this helps to make comments
Lint helps you find more in your code
We were also on co-operation with FREIF RESEARCH
At the University of Oregon to work on permits
This is still in progress
But when it's finished, lets you move your app
To Android's final permissions
Here I can call this act
It helps me to make the right requests
And handling the callback of Android's final licenses
[clap]
We also have manufacturing armament to remove unused resources
So if you add some unused resources in fact
I can now delete the re-manufacturing list
Selecting the removal of unused resources and integrated development environments
Find and remove them for you
This helps make your application lighter
[clap]
Okay
The last thing I want to show you is the Espresso test recorder
I hear the enthusiasm of the audience
Okay
To do this, all I have to do is enter into my project
Then enter the execution menu and press the espresso test register
They noted that Espresso was not an "Expresso"
When I do, you can see
They build the application
He starts recording the event on the left here
On the right, the application works
If I can now go, for example
On this category here and you can see
He records her event
I can press the back button
And then go down and press
On the music button
They noticed while I was clicking, recording events here
He tries to understand what he is pressing
For example when you press the red button
He records that I press the Test Fashion button
There's something nice I can do while I sign up
Is to add affirmations
If I click the "Add confirmation" button here
Now a screenshot and a hierarchical view appear
What happens in the application
Now you can see that I can walk around
In the logical form of the application
If pressed, for example
To the question: "Who was the youngest member of the Beetle band?"
This displays and suggests
Confirmation, that is at this stage
When the app is running, wait
To be this series: "Who was the youngest individual in the Beetle band?"
[clap]
Then click on "Save confirmation" and continue to work
Is there anyone - I will press some wrong answers
Until they stop me
Okay?
Error
Still wrong
George is right
Okay?
Then click the Delivery button
You can see here that the answer was correct
I think it is enough
For the test recording part
Now I will press "End registration"
When I do that, ask me what class that is
I want to save the test
I will accept the default
Here is our espresso test
Notice that I pressed wrong things at first
I can edit this test if you want
For example, I can pull the option of pressing the wrong button
And return
Then I run the test
To do so
If all I have to do is press the play button here
You can also use cloud scanning
I do not have enough time, but you can register
Then the user interface checks on the number
Of various hidden model factors
It is very useful
Okay
To restart this on the emulator
If he builds the examination, he publishes it to take a look
On the right here, when the application starts working
Because he can press him faster than me
Install APK, here we click
And we have the green light
Okay
[clap]
Thanks
However, I will move
To (Jamal), who will speak
For Visual Editor
[clap]
(Miss Eason): Thank you, (Tor), a wonderful show
If it is presented (Tor) to you is what we do
I'll take some time to talk
Why we have worked and what you might want to integrate
In your progress in development
For design, we think of two main themes:
XML and designs
For XML, I know that some of you like the full UI design
In XML, this is great
But for me and many others
It's nice to have a kind of tool for visualization
Allows you to see how your app is translated
And our team set a goal, as we think
Can we create a tool
Does not require editing XML?
Of course this means you can look at your code
Later, but should not be in the way
Towards your work
This was the reason for the new design editor
As you view (Tor), you have a full set of features
Especially ways to pull tools into the tree of elements
To the design interface or schema status,
Allowing you to look behind your app
See how to link all your tools together
Finally, the new properties panel
Previously, it was showing you all the different properties
Available for viewing
Now, we have organized and introduced
The most effective properties for your presentation design
The second question we were thinking about
It is about what designs
For Android designs, you have some different options
You have a longitudinal design, of course horizontal and longitudinal
But you might think that maybe
I want to use the design of the design table
Hey, this will not actually work
To think about the use of network design or relative design
Hey, what should we use here?
This is the problem we are trying to think about
Because many times, you may think about any of the varieties
Which I want to use in my designs?
If linear design is the solution
For this problem, you can think less about the class
More about content and how to design
Your tools on your designs
Let us talk about why you use it
Linear design
First, it is a rapid development of the user interface
As you saw in the demo, you can
Add tools quickly and connect
All different restrictions
More importantly think about it
Is that this will help you produce a more responsive design
Instead of thinking about what
My screen is for a Nexus 4 phone, a tablet, or a Nexus 6
We can now put restrictions
Which allows you to respond to content according to size
the screen
The third most important aspect is performance
As you have seen in the show
We can find a hierarchy for you
If you do not know that, if you put a relative design
Under a longitudinal design and other relative design,
This slows the Android system
Operational work
So we have settled all this overlap
In the new spatial design
Finally, it is identical to reverse work
That is, you can use it for new projects
But the support library is
Which allows you to use it in existing projects as well
[clap]
If the third tool we offered about the design
Is a design monitor
Sometimes when you download your app
You may wonder why the offer is intertwined
Or maybe why not one of the properties
As I expected to be?
If you can now do with our tools
Is clicking on the right and taking a screenshot
For your current design and visual inspection
For all the different properties and look at the hierarchy of presentation
Full of your design
This should be useful in error handling
Now is the time to speak a little
About the "phase" and tools
Which we did to help you do that
As we mentioned in the show, we have a new Firebase extension
This supports the new Firebase services
Which we launched yesterday in Google IE
Now you can add things like Google Analytics and Ads
And cloud messages, all with the click of a button inside
Android Studio 2.0
The other great thing we talked about was the model browser
As we offered, if you are looking
About the API example of how to use something
We now provide the power of all Google models
At the click of a button
This is easy for you
Search and find a good starting point
To develop your application
So I would like to talk
A little about construction tools
I will call (Steve) to talk about these two changes
STEVE CATHBERTSEN: Awesome
[clap]
Thank you very much (Jamal)
For "construction", I would like to start talking about immediate operation
As a developer, I think one is better
Feelings in the world is a sense of total harmony
And one of our goals in Android
Is to make Android development
As light as web development
If you can make changes to your code
You see it fundamentally and it changes
In order to stay in perfect harmony while working on your code
That is why we have built immediate operation
I want to talk a little bit about how it works
The integrated development environment changes your changes in one of three ways
For incremental changes, we do the quickest switch
We call it hot switch
Here's what you do is equip
Byte code on the first version
And then, when you make changes
We only convert the code path to capture the changed code
The second type of switch is the warm switch
This is when we need to restart the activity
If this is what you need when you are doing
Such as resource changes
A cold switch is when we need to restart the application
This is required when you make structural changes
The proverbs are so changes to genetics
Or if you change the signature of the medium
What I would like to do is turn back and unload a bit
Some of the performance metrics we talked about yesterday
In the basic subject
We benchmark performance using a wide range of different applications
And various tools
I will not give them just one example
We set a benchmark for the Wikipedia application
It is an open-source application, and you can get it on GitHub
All of our standards have been published here
If we want to repeat them
What you notice is that we are setting a performance benchmark other than version 2.0
Instant playback is off
You can see that in version 2.1 with cold switch
It is 4.7 times faster while the hot switch is 10.7 times faster
Now what that means, if you think about it
Is that the speed of our construction actually faster than 10 times, because we
We put performance measures without 2.0 and version 2.0 faster than 1.5
Because of the changes we made in Dex
We also made the Android protocol for debugging 10 times faster
We are tweaking our value a bit
But what matters most to us is
You get very fast construction
This is what we have focused on
This gives us a fair comparison
In our performance metrics
To talk about another type of performance measure we are doing
Look at the user statistics for the subscribed users
We are prepared in a variety of different ways
For those of you, thank you
This is an example of the statistic we look at
Represents the average construction time for immediate operation on the hot switch
This statistic displays all users
If this is universal, on all operating systems
In all states and on all computer components
This includes very old components with slow processors
And things like that
What you see is that most users
They see the hot switch in four or five seconds or less
Our goal is always to push this figure to its limits
Try to get as much as possible in one second
If what we are looking for is trying to identify
How to take down the full build speed
Make hot switch faster and how to make
The largest number of possible substitutions of hot relays
If we look at things from this point of view
Look at the hot and warm switch distribution
Cold and full construction times, as we look at
What causes the cold switch
And to consider these measurement tools
Truly, all of your data is brilliant
Is what gave us proof of one of the big changes you will see in version 2.2
2.2 contains changes in the AAPT
And many of you know when a resource changes, enters the AAPT
Explanation of ID instructions in data
What you do not know maybe and what we do not know
Is that if you change a resource or add a new resource
AAPT was renumbering the interpreter instructions
The result is that you are changing the code
But you get a cool change
We determined that this caused about 16 to 19%
Of our cold substitutions
If with version 2.2, we changed the AAPT to load
Explains instructions for resources in a consistent manner
If I take you somewhere in a round the backstage
What will happen to you in version 2.2 is faster than immediate operation
Because you will see a lot of hot relays
The other change we have made is that we are using Split APK
Now, when you build, it will break your application
To about 11 to 12 Dex files
And when you build a full
We are rebuilding the code that has changed only
We plan to take down construction speed
In several consecutive versions and not in version 2.2
So if you're still experiencing slow construction speeds
Our engineering team will appreciate
If you communicate with us
Let's talk about the structure of the project
Now, Tor (View) introduced our amazing
I will give you the look behind the scenes
At the bottom of the project structure dialogue
You will find interesting changes to the Gradle building model
Gradle was amazing to us
It is a very flexible and very powerful language for Android
But let's think about it
The integrated development environment expects the organization input
And Gradle programming language
It is therefore very complex
One of the changes we made in version 2.2
Is that we have rewritten the Gradle parser from below to
the above
What this means is that we are now more accurate
When we read the files in Gradle as we are
More accurate in the integrated development environment when we rewrite it
An example of what you will see, for example
If you type the variables in the Gradle file
It will be read correctly in the integrated development environment
And in the future, in the project structure dialogue
You will also be able to modify it in the user interface
[clap]
The Gradle Rewrite Form was completed in version 2.2
As Tor stated, the project structure dialogue
Completely completed in version 2.2
You'll be able to try it under a beta tag
We plan to complete it in version 2.3, at that point
It will be default
This is a beautiful screenshot to display the merged data
(Tor)
I would like to skip a step forward to talk about
Jack
The Jack interpreter is integrated with Gradle in version 2.1
In version 2.2, we included comment processing
You can use comment processors on the category path
[clap]
This includes, for example, translation reliability
It will be applied automatically
Now we will give you detailed information on how to use them in our documents
Among the things I wanted to mention here is in Google IE
If you are someone who writes tools and works
On pre and post processing in class files
One of the beautiful things about Jack
Is that it has a structural API for processors
We will look to move more and more Jack
In future releases
So try it please
Let us know if there is any shortage
The last topic we ask is C ++ support
So I will give you a comprehensive picture of what we are doing
Because I think it's a nice way to understand C ++ from the party
To the party
The reason behind our big investment
Is that we know that many of you are building
Rich graphics applications and games
You talked to us and you told us that C ++ is essential
We support editing and debugging C ++
All this comes through IntelliJ
So among the new things you will get in 2016.1
The new IntelliJ support is optimized for C ++
But I think the biggest change you'll see in version 2.2
Is CMake and Gradle
To give you an example of CMake
You can refer the CMake project to the Gradle file
This builds the so.
To be packaged in the APK
The Gradle now delivers work to CMake
We urge CMake to emit more metadata
In the same project, in how it is built
And what files inside the project
This shows you how, as presented to you (Tor)
You can see cpp files. In the hierarchy of the project
You will receive. Also
If they are in the same file
The same files will appear in a node in the project hierarchy
Under external construction files
So you can also edit it from the integrated development environment
As Tor said, you can
Run the application, set a breakpoint and will all work as expected
NDKBuild is installed as itself
So you can forward the mk file. For Android from your build model
I would also like to take you on a quick tour of C ++ debugger improvements
First in version 2.2, as we mentioned
You should not choose C ++, Java,
Or hybrid debugger, you can use the automatic option
The integrated development environment will choose the appropriate debugger
for you
If correct in Android N system, you can use
One debugger for Java and C ++
And there's something we've finally added, the stops
You can add a variable
The process is frozen if the red color is shown or marked
Stop points can be used on x86 and Nexus 9
We plan to add more devices
Until then, the wonderful way to experience it
Is by experimenting with our simulators
We have also fixed many matching problems
With Samsung S5 and S6 devices
If we mention everything about C ++ in version 2.2, you should keep seeing
Improvements in upcoming releases
The last point we would like to talk about is the examination
For this, I would like to move back to (Jamal)
Thank you very much
[clap]
Beauty Eason: So for the examination
The basic feature you need is the local scan environment
So we are very excited to launch the Android Simulator
At the beginning of this year
If you have not tried it yet, it's a great tool
What makes it great is that we are well CPU
Graphics processing unit and I / O speeds, becomes faster than the device
As well as the speeds of the Android protocol for debugging
Believe it or not, the alleys are between
Your payment for your assets and your application is an Android protocol for debugging
It is ten times faster with the new Android simulator
And of course, as you view (Tor)
We have a new user interface
You can do things like screen layout and screen capture
But there is also an extended user interface
Which allows you to control the sensors
Such as a location, or send a text message
Or make phone calls and all tools allow you to examine your application
[clap]
In addition to local screening
We also launched Firebase Lab for testing
Inside the Android Studio
So if you click on your tab for zipper
Which is displayed (Tor), allows you to
Choose devices on the cloud
Now you can turn on a device that you might not have
Try to send your application and check with it
To help you check your application
As I mentioned earlier, we have an espresso test recorder
This is a fantastic demo
The reason why this is important
Find us that making tests is heavy
And sometimes does not like a lot of people do
So now, you can press your device
We can take all these tests
You can upload them to the testing lab
Or run locally on your device
Finally we talked about APK parser
I repeat, the importance of this is that sometimes you
You think that you have completed the work, and built your application
But your APK is too large
Because in the end, your users want
Who carry your app from Google Play
The smallest APK is possible
So this tool allows you to dive into your application
Search the files and your dex assets
And identify the problem because my application is too large
We do not have time to talk about every feature
But we talked about the new Lint analysis and the new Intellijs 2016 features
We have invested heavily in easy access
All new features we added
Inside Android Studio 2.2
In short, we launched a full range of features
In the design and management of new restricted setup
And a trial recorder to help you check
How do you start?
All you have to do, if you're using Android Studio 2.2 today
Is going to check for updates
We will ask you to download Android Studio 2.2
In Canary Channel
If you do not use Android Studio
Enter this link and upload a new version
Again, change the channel to Canary
Download Android 2.2 Studio
That's all we have
Thank you so much
Thanks